i will talk a little bit about
the ignatius
and
and among my friends and in another job
this framework was very used and very
known but recently i changed jobs and
in this new job well there was a
different things
what is ness js
yes
it's a framework
it's almost a new one and for me
personally it's a very complete one so
let's know a little bit more about this
about me my name is hareliviana i'm a
software engineer web developer
i've been in this industry for four
years now and i'm from el salvador but i
love to travel that's why right now i'm
in mexico city and the languages that i
work is ruby javascript and php
among my hobbies well i have
some of them but i love a
photograph climber and painter
the
hey
the agenda for our talk first of all is
what is the concept of
net yes and why do i think this is the
best what makes it special
and then we are going to have a demo
built in appi
and last but not least the q a session
well
what is it
nes yes
it's creator
is a
framework in a very
extensible versatile and progressive and
in just one
way i can say it that
this framework is like the brother of
angular if you already work with angular
you remember that this is uh this is
also a framework and as a matter of fact
this framework is
inspired and based in the other
architecture so if you already know
angular you will see there are very
similar thing between the two of them
and the characteristics are very
important is extensible versatile and
progressive
when i say extensible this means that is
a
modular architecture and with this
is very flexible
we can use several libraries from the
call the external libraries or and also
is versatile
because it can adapt itself to any app
and it's very solid
app and with other frameworks and also
it's progressive and this means that is
updated
with the
last functions of javascript and also we
can't also take into account or maximize
the
solid and also because it's a framework
there is a set of tools
in these tools we can find
well you can work with node
it's also very
strongly
to use typescript
because it's a very flexible framework
it's
it's a recommendation and your life will
be easier
also
it can be adapted to two types of orm
the one is type of rm and the other one
is prisma
i've worked with both of them and
personally i love prisma
but both are
very important as orms
and
below
of this framework it uses a lot of
express
and you can have the
option of using fast five on the server
part you can have rest and grave
hql
we can present our app as a rest api
or graph hql
what does it solve
what is so special
compare with other framework
well with this one we have an
established architecture that is
proposing like
a very
older way and if you have already worked
with angular or vue framework
they don't have like a very strict
architecture but it's very easy it's
easier so you can have this structure
and our team can follow it
so the project can be
very well done
and because this architecture is very
complete you can scale scalable your
project
if you want to grow up
so
this how is this architecture look like
well here are the basic concept
is this is not like a law we can adapt
according to our project needs
but these are like the main concept
decorators
is a structural design pattern
and i put it here because you can use it
a lot
a lot in this framework
dtos
entities everywhere
if you don't know what is a decorator is
like
functions where we can
uh calculate and allocate things in
other places
the basic architecture from the
controller file
well we can handle
providers
controllers
providers can do a set of things
maybe a service a repository helpers
and we can use it in our files
and
such as angular well they use a modular
architecture
what i say when i say model is this a
group of files that share something for
example
there is a model
well and this is new for you but my
presentation is full with cats because
the icon of this framework is a cat so
i'm honoring this type of framework
the module that i will present you is
about cats
and we are going to have different files
services controllers repositories
and
they are going to share
those files in the same model
and or and all of them are related with
one unity
also we have middlewares
there this is a layer that comes before
and when there is a response
and with
i mean we have our front end
and we do like a repetition in the in
our api
and then we have the writer and the
controller
and in that process
in the middle is the middleware so
is when we can do different things like
validations transformations
of data
and that's why we can
use this layer
and the other filters pipes guards and
interceptors
i think they are
are like middle whales but ness propose
this concept separately so we can have
in an orderly way
and we can have like like step by step
and we can know
where this is going to be executed
so in this presentation we are going to
base in these four concepts
we can
see a lot of examples but
let's see what i prepare
and also
where we are going to focus on in the
client side the middle way the road
handle and we can process all of this
and then we return to the client side
and we can have all these steps
so let's see
each and every one of them
let's see filters
ness gs
has a main filter to handle
sections
if there is one section in any point of
the api
well
you
you can
filter and don't see
everything so long for example
an error
however we can create our own filters
and that's what we are going to see in
our example
then the second one is pipes and
it can transform or validate data
and when i say this what i meant is if
we have a string parameter and we want
to change it with other data
and then validate is
we have an input from an email and we
want to validate that it's an email
format
and then the cards
well according to certain conditions
well
through these ones we are going to
validate if we can process information
or not
also here we use
normally like an authorization or
authentication
authentication is if the main user is
the one
and
and if it's logging
or different roles
that
part of the application must have this
card so if there's some mistake or for
like for example one 403
we cannot allow the user what is
happening
and last we have interceptors so
intercept a response or a route or to
alter or rewrite what is in that
in our example we are going to see
or we are going to use this concept
to
map our response
and the standard
how the answer should be in the api
okay
let's uh start with our demo
these are the com the commands that i
use
and
the project is already done but i will
explain you the important areas or
sections
first
okay
first we install the
cli of nest
then
that cli
allowed us to create a project when we
want to start with a server we
[Music]
we need to check that our server is
running
and then some packages that i use is
typo rom
nes confi
to handle all the configuration files
i also use a class validator library
and i use
that library to validate some things in
the project
this is like a scaffolding nest
gas
resource create everything that has to
do with controllers dtos
services other files and the model all
my cad model
will have with this resource
for the examples
i have a guard
a filter and an interceptor
i also use
the flags
because i want that folder to be saved
so let's see a little bit of this more
about this project
so this is what we already see
and let's start with our server
so we can check that everything is
working out
and
i have a little problem here and we are
going to change
the version
okay
let's run the server
here you can see with the logs that
everything is working out and also
i already
have something already programmed
this is like the post to create cats get
to have all these cats
another get
to
specifically
have the information of just one cat
a patch to edit and a delete to delete
it
so let's try it out
i use postman and insomnia
but for mac
i could not install
pokemon
so i have this one
as you can see
i have here
my my endpoints let's try the first one
and i can have all the information about
cats
i have the show create delete and update
very fast let's start seeing in the the
scaffolding as i already mentioned this
creates a lot of files and the cad model
is all this
i have my cats model where is i'm
injecting all the things that i need for
example controllers providers cat
service
what is happening there
and i'm importing
time or model that is
these repositories to
connect directly
so let's see first the service
the service it just has
the
the constructor functions create find
all find
one
and framework utility uses a lot of
injecting these services
and also another repository the num the
name is type o rm
in this way we already have access to
this cat repository
to create we are using these parameters
a dto
dto is a
file where we can declare
which
things we need to connect through the
net
for example
create
the user
can be able to send me these parameters
and
we also use a library to validate
i use an iss string is optional is
volume
or if it's an email
i can write down this
this different type that i can use
i have also the dto
to update cats that
partially extend this function and this
partial type also
comes from this library mapped types and
what is it doing is telling the dto
that all of them can be optional
not like this one
this parameter
is that i don't want to be empty
entities is super basic
tool
with all these attributes id
name bio
a code
and maybe if it's adopted or no
in another framework we have a migration
concept in
and next years also has it and
right now i don't have this function
but
through
side
variable i'm telling that when i write
or i change something in my entity
automatically
this will be synchronized
this
file
is
here in configuration
and
i have this type from the nest library
and i have all the steps
that i need to write down and also the
synchronization
this
file all this constant
we have in a main model that
need to have an sgs up
and
there is where you inject
all the dependency or the other models
that we are going to need in that app
the app model you can see it like this
i'm importing my
type or
file and i'm
injecting
in this one
in this way we can synchronize
both of them
let's go back
with our
demo
we
have
okay we're going to see a lot of
decorators
if
i can write down if i want a notable
unique
uuid
or maybe a default value and the type of
data the length the type
so we
can check it out because i have
this is my database
and my charts
as you can see
i have everything here
how to generate false
the sequence because with this decorator
i'm telling to create a column
and will be the main key
or the primary key just here
uniqueness is the code
and all of this i don't need to write
all
the creatively
and variable declaration and attributes
i don't know i don't need to
to do all that
that's why the decorators are there
let's
we already talked about dtos and
services let's check out controller
i'm using a lot of decorators
in the controller
i
have cats
because i want base cut of this line
is cats
if i write here for example in spanish
gatos
this will change and not cats but gatos
for the root
or the string is what i need is is my
ids
and what i said this framework uses a
lot of
injection
and another framework are
files dedicated to routes or path
and i put the http and i'm calling that
from library
and that's it
with this framework the path or the root
is with this such a verb or another
instruction
this is like the basic of our main
app and now let's see
the middleware concept
i already show you the middlewares and
the
instruction and
in any project i love to use
this option
and nes
will give you one but
in this case i want that my exception
has more data for example details and to
show me the
time or the date
i if i want to change this to 26
i'm telling the time
where where this request was done
the status and the message
and i can add any other key
i also add some things for example
response
and it's a link to the
message key but if it's an array
sorry really
we you need to summarize because we have
another talk
okay
so because we are running out of time i
will
but
this presentation
well the code
is in my github
i will
you will see step by step in a very
detailed way how to handle
this and sgs filters interceptors and
everything else
and the last that i want to show you
is how to handle
uh
a beautiful format for a response i add
the data the income data and i can
add metadata
so
like
this it's not working but for example in
this exam it did i can add that is a
collection or different type of metadata
whatever
and well i had other concepts of pipes
but the last thing that i want to share
with you it will show you is that we can
handle filters and guards in a global or
partial way
the the this file
and if we want to handle something
partially we can do it directly with
controllers
or
or a token
and i use a guard
in the controller level
here
we can see the logger
if there is any error or mistake
and there's a lot of advantages of this
framework unfortunately we cannot see it
all of them with this little time
but anything
i don't know if you can share my
presentation
so we can see the last slide
i will tell you i will leave you some
recommendation and my contact
information linkedin twitter and
instagram so you can check it out the
repo and also you can send me an email
if you want more information well i can
show you a lot of resources
thank you very much